this video is sponsored by the book
summary service blinkist the first 100
people to use the link in the
description will receive one free week
of unlimited access and 25 off a full
membership
whether it's some sort of brain teaser a
personal observation a visual or sound
or a seemingly unresolvable problem
within math science and philosophy every
time we try to make sense of something
through accurate consistent premises and
logic but no matter how hard we try fail
to do so we encounter what is known as a
paradox
these strange intersections of knowledge
and ignorance absurdity and simplicity
intuitively true yet apparently false
can not only bend the mind in harmless
brain teasers and puzzles but can also
reveal hugely significant insights into
the nature of human thinking and its
limitations
the word paradox originates from the
greek word paradoxin which translates
into distinct from our opinion nowadays
the term is often applied to a variety
of things in a variety of contexts be it
literature math science philosophy logic
economics perception as well as many
other looser pseudo applications
in terms of a more complete contemporary
philosophical definition a paradox
occurs when you start out with a set of
premises that are understood to be true
or at least believed to be you evaluate
and follow the premises through accurate
consistent logic and then determine
their conclusion however despite this
despite everything else being true and
in the right order the conclusion
appears false impossible inconsistent or
absurd
however despite all appearing under the
same umbrella not all paradoxes are
equal and not all paradoxes are actually
paradoxical
in his book the ways of paradox and
other essays philosopher and logician
willard van orman kwine explores into
the nature of paradoxes and standardizes
three separate distinct categories what
he would classify as falsitical
veritical and antinomy
to help illustrate the first category
falsitical consider one of the classic
motion paradoxes from 400 bc greek
philosopher xeno of alia known as the
arrow paradox
the arrow paradox argues that an arrow
flying through the air is at rest
xeno argues for this by claiming that in
each single isolated instant of time
that the arrow is flying it is in one
specific isolated position in space
unmoving in this moment the arrow cannot
be moving to where it is because it is
already there nor can it be moving to
where it is not because no time has
elapsed in this isolated moment
thus xeno concludes in every one of
these individual moments no motion is
occurring and since time is composed of
a string of all these individual moments
then no motion is ever occurring at all
thus the flying arrow is at rest
at first and at the time of zeno this
argument might somehow sound correct but
of course in reality we know that the
arrow is in motion this is what makes it
initially paradoxical
however this particular paradox is
considered falsitical which are
according to quine paradoxes that appear
to be true based on a certain logical
assessment within a certain state or
condition of knowledge and understanding
but said state is fallacious in some
sense lacking the necessary insight to
resolve the paradox the paradox however
is capable of being resolved and made
non-paradoxical
in this particular case xeno's argument
is falicious because it assumes at least
one or more false premises to be true
firstly it assumes that an instant of
time can be divisible into a finitely
small moment or chunk that can last zero
units of itself but time cannot be made
into non-time if time is made of units
equal to zero and you multiply or divide
any measure of time by this you would
simply always have zero time this would
essentially render time inexistent and
if we are to agree that time in at least
some sense does exist then this premise
would be false
rather time must be infinitely divisible
into instance that still contains some
vanishingly minute degree of elapsing
duration
secondly motion is improperly defined by
zeno as well motion is not measured in
abstract isolation and singular
dimensionless moments rather motion
necessitates that an object is in
different places at different times
xeno's arrow perhaps brings up some
metaphysical questions about time but in
terms of physics with the right
sufficient information considered from
the correct angle the paradox is
understood to be false or falsitical
quine's next category veritical are
paradoxes that also appear false at
first but in this case not because they
are made by false premises or faulty
logic but rather the premises are in
fact true the logic used is in fact
correct and the conclusion is in fact
also true it only appears false however
because its truth runs counter to our
initial intuitions
this can be exemplified most simply by
one of bertrand russell's paradoxes the
barber paradox in which imagine a small
town with only one barber this
particular barber shaves all and only
men who do not shave themselves
initially this seems fairly
straightforward but the paradox is such
a barber can never exist
this might sound like an extreme jump or
false claim at first but it's true which
is what makes it vertical
when considering the following question
it becomes clearer does the barber shave
himself
if he does not then he is part of the
group which he does shave since he
shaves those who do not shave themselves
but if he is in this group then he does
shave himself but if he does shave
himself then he cannot be the barber
since the barber only shaves those who
do not shave themselves
thus we have an inescapable
contradiction and no barber can ever
exist in such a condition
the important part of this paradox being
vertical is not merely the inescapable
contradiction but that taken from the
position that no such barber can exist
the paradox simply demonstrates that an
initially obvious or simple seeming
statement can be logically impossible
upon further consideration
the third and final category from
quine's analysis is what he classified
as antinomies this category is what we
most likely think of when we think of a
paradox and arguably this is by far the
most interesting and relevant kind
according to kwine antinomies are
paradoxes that achieve a contradictory
or absurd conclusion even by correctly
applying true premises and consistent
logic they defy all accepted laws of
logic and information and for some don't
even appear to be resolvable by any
conceivable information at all
they create in quine's words a crisis in
thought
and ironically they can come in as
little as a three to four word statement
consider the following
this statement is false
this forward statement implodes all
logic if the statement is true then the
statement is false but if the statement
is false then the statement is true for
the statements claim that it is false to
be true necessitates it being false and
vice versa add infinitum there is no way
out no rope of logic to escape with
another similar example includes the
statement there is no truth
likewise this statement is inescapably
self-contradictory if there is no truth
then this statement itself cannot be
true and therefore must be false but if
the statement is false it must be true
that there is no truth and the statement
is true but if the statement is true
there must be no truth and again it must
be false and then repeat over and over
other antinomy paradoxes that are a bit
more involved and seem to imply
different sorts of gaps between their
conclusion and reality include problems
like the fermi paradox which reveals the
contradiction between the strong logic
that there are exceptionally high odds
for there being other advanced
extraterrestrial life scattered
throughout the galaxy and there being no
signs of any
also the faint young sun paradox which
reveals the contradiction between
astrophysical understandings that the
output of earth's sun would have only
been about 70 percent as intense during
earth's early history while simultaneous
evidence shows that earth had the
presence of liquid water and life during
the same time with relatively consistent
temperatures which would be impossible
if the sun's output was that low
one could also go so far to include
problems like the entire origins of the
cosmos often summarized by the question
why is there something rather than
nothing as in how did something
apparently come from nothing or how has
something always been this appears
absolutely inconceivable to answer in
any way that makes any sense
also the very nature of our personal
subjective experience as self-conscious
beings at the very least has strong
traces of an antinomy paradox summarized
by the hard problem of consciousness how
does physical activity in the brain
equate to a subjective felt state of
being arguably there appears to be no
concept or evidence that could ever
really answer how this is possible
antinamis paradoxes of this broader form
seem to exist at the very foundation of
our being from the origins of the cosmos
all the way down into the very core of
our consciousness
existence as a whole is perhaps the
greatest unresolvable paradox
throughout different periods of history
and for different people like zeno and
his cohorts in 400 bc paradoxes that
were once believed with conviction to be
antinomies have since become falsitical
with the advent of new knowledge and
understanding
we now know how and why zeno's math and
arguments were wrong in his motion
paradoxes and so it is fair to assume
that this will also occur for some
portion of what appear to be antinomies
today sometime in the future
however arguably it is overzealously
romantic to assume that all or even most
will and more yet will not other new
paradoxes emerge in time alongside old
ones being resolved creating an endless
loop never really allowing for the
resolution of man's intrinsic
relationship with paradox
ultimately no paradox is ever resolved
without some cost something must be
broken our current knowledge must reveal
faulty or our ability to ever really
think consistently and accurately about
reality must reveal incompetent
in cases like this statement is false
what information could possibly be
missing that would resolve this paradox
or in the cases of perceptual paradoxes
and so on perhaps some paradoxes are
more like shorts in the wiring of our
brain and our language rather than some
missing
information what we cannot speak about
we must pass over in silence
wrote ludwig wittgenstein
although the human mind is the most
powerful and impressive thing that it
itself is aware of it can only visually
perceive about
.0035 percent of the electromagnetic
spectrum can only hear between 20 hertz
to 20 kilohertz of all possible audio
frequencies and can only know what it
thinks it knows
paradoxes at least of a certain kind
perhaps situate themselves at the outer
perimeter of our minds abilities
revealing to us what we cannot
comprehend within the limits of the
comprehensible
on these paradoxes we seemingly stand on
the cliff of our understanding knowing
where we are while looking out at a vast
looming valley covered in fog
paradoxes challenge us to continually
explore this valley to fill it in with
new checkpoints and create new maps of
understanding but perhaps there are
simply unresolvable paradoxes within
this valley areas we can likely just
never see or discover or perhaps
antinomies don't even really exist at
all and all paradoxes are merely created
by human fallacy that can be resolved or
perhaps the opposite all things are
fundamentally paradoxical and all
resolutions are contrived by false human
meaning
whatever the case may be the valley is
likely far too big and we are likely far
too small to ever know for sure
ultimately the fact that any amount of
our existence can make any sense and
that any amount of paradoxes past or
present have and can be resolved by us
it's a paradox in it of itself
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blinkist
consider one more following paradox a
woman named sarah has just discovered
the book summary app blinkist on which
she can read or listen to thousands of
complete non-fiction book summaries each
summary being just around 15 minutes
because of this convenience she plans on
reading and engaging in more books on a
regular basis the first book summary she
listens to is the power of habit by
charles duhigg where she learns about
the science behind creating and
reshaping habits in life it's so
convenient and informative she continues
on to her second book nudge immediately
after she enjoys this summary so much
she decides to listen to the complete
audiobook that blinkist also provides
directly within the app after listening
to both summaries and the audiobook
sarah feels more knowledgeable and
informed but of course she still feels
like the same sarah soon sarah develops
a habit of reading at least five
summaries on blinkist every week at the
end of each summary her level of
knowledge continues to increase but
still of course she feels like the same
person over the course of the following
year sarah reads more than 200 book
summaries and listens to almost 50
audiobooks on blinkist now however
compared to when she started a year ago
she feels like a completely different
person with a huge array of new
knowledge different habits and behaviors
that she's learned and a new expertise
in finance after each new book summary
that sarah read she always felt like the
same person but by the end of the total
sum of all the books at the end of the
year she felt like a completely
different person at what point then did
sarah become a different person
can it be pinpointed if not how did she
become a different person or did she at
all
this is a reinterpretation of the
paradox known as the ship of theseus
with over 27 categories and thousands of
titles blinkist makes it easy for just
about anyone to become a new improved
version of themselves even if you can't
be sure exactly when and how you became
it
the first 100 people to use the link in
the description will receive one free
week of unlimited access as well as 25
off of full membership the free 7-day
trial can be cancelled at any time
within the trial period and of course
thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video
you